i want to look at one more clip from
this reawaken america thing as many of
you know
donald trump is not a religious guy
donald trump is not a spiritual guy
donald trump has had out of necessity
because he was running as a republican
to start kind of pretending to be
religious when he wanted to become the
republican nominee and so he started
saying that the bible is his favorite
book up there with the the book he wrote
which he didn't even really write he had
a ghostwriter but fine with his own book
the art of the deal and he would try to
tell little anecdotes about two
corinthians and this type of thing
but when he was asked like what's your
favorite bible verse he didn't even have
an answer he said well it's too personal
i don't even want to talk about it he
now has found a very spiritual of
spiritual opposition to abortion as many
of you know all of this stuff is
completely contrived there's nothing
spiritual at all about donald trump and
quite frankly i don't think there is
about his kids either
but eric trump in particular has really
been playing up the religious thing i
think it might be because eric trump is
kind of the most dim-witted one don jr
has
his whole thing that he's used to get
attention ivanka is less interested in
being in the spotlight and anyway she
converted to judaism and there's a lot
of anti-semitism on the right so it's
not like she's gonna necessarily play up
a religion but eric trump's niche has
been
playing up his religiosity playing up
his spirituality and going to events
like the overtly religious reawaken
america tour so he spoke over the
weekend and he made the claim that he
makes his four-year-old say the pledge
of allegiance every night
along with some prayers and he mentions
in this the anti-antifa code of
destruction which is not not a text i'm
familiar with check this out if this is
real it's horrible and if he's lying
it's horrible that it's the type of
thing that would help ingratiate him
with the audience take a look
and literally the second week i'm there
i've got a little four-year-old luke he
comes home from school and we say
prayers every night together right we
have these little three kind of family
prayers that we say and the lord's
prayer to others
okay do any of us believe that every
night
eric trump and his four-year-old say
three prayers like
i don't know if they do it's fine but i
just have a very hard time believing
that but now we go into the pledge of
allegiance let's make him stand up put
his hand on his heart and do the pledge
of allegiance and so i go luke i'm going
to teach you the pledge of allegiance
tonight he goes oh dad i pledge
allegiance to the flag in the united
states he does the whole thing and i go
you know in new york they would have
taught him the antifa code
of destruction right like literally
anybody know what that is the antifa
code of destruction that that's not a
that's not something i've ever heard of
they're not doing the pledge of
allegiance in new york that much i can
tell you but
why is it that we have this war on the
flag on red white and blue why is it
that we have this war on the pledge of
allegiance why is it that you have
people tearing down
statues of our historical figures why is
it that
you know like they want to rewrite
the governing documents of of this
country they're trying to change history
they're trying to change some of the
greatest
fake he doesn't even know what the hell
he's talking about so if it's true that
he forces the pledge of allegiance onto
his four-year-old every night it's
horrifying if it's a lie it's horrifying
that it's the type of thing he thinks
would convince people in the audience to
like him and i sort of suspect this
isn't really happening
i'm not really thinking that donald ever
uh tucked eric trump into bed at night
uh and it seems to me like not exactly
the type of family that would really uh
uh be doing this at night that that's
just my instinct but it is an absolutely
fascinating family in that sense i do
feel bad for those kids and the pledge
of allegiance does feel really
antiquated i remember when i first moved
to the united states
it i think it was in first grade we were
i was introduced to the pledge of
allegiance and it always struck me as a
little bit weird
and what i always did was i would mouth
the words to look like i was
participating you know peer pressure i
was a kid but i wouldn't actually say
them because it felt so cringy and
creepy and bizarre
and then i don't know i have like a i
have the memory that it just kind of
stopped i don't know if it might have
been that in middle school the pledge of
allegiance instead of being done at the
classroom level was done like over the
loudspeaker where the whole school would
do it but then it just faded out i don't
know if it was while i was in middle
school or maybe when i went to high
school it's not really clear
um but uh it's a strange thing to be
doing in school
and it seems bizarre to be doing it
every night before going to bed i don't
even believe he's actually doing it it's
worse if he's doing it but i don't even
believe that he's actually doing it let
me know what you think